la vitesse maximale de cette voiture est
de 60 kilomètres heure environ la
distance qu'on peut parcourir sur route
sans arrêt et de l'ordre de 100 à 110 km
en ville elle est de l'ordre de 60 à 70
km c'est une voiture qui est très
silencieuse les moteurs électriques en
général faisant très peu du coup
[Musique]
non c'est un prototype à moteur
électrique une batterie
une commande qui est soit une commande
électro mécaniques seule commande
électronique
hon 6 motos qui ne pollue absolument pas
aller très très simple à conduire
puisque vous n'avez que deux pétales une
[ __ ] pour contrôler l'accélération et
une [ __ ] pour le frein vous n'avez
plus de [ __ ] d'embrayage est également
vous avez un inverseur de sens de marche
c'est à dire se sentent marche avant ou
marche arrière pour des questions
d'allègement nous avons fait réaliser
une carrosserie en plastique le pare
brise et le pare-brise d'origine par
contre les glaces latérales sont en
plexiglas nous l'avons passé devant le
service des mines qui a donné son accord
pour la circulation sur route
l'utilisation la plus simple et une
utilisation donc du véhicule pendant la
journée et une recharge pendant la nuit
soit dans votre garage salir à l'aide
d'une prise de courant soit
éventuellement dans des parkings équipés
à cet effet il n'ya pas encore mais
c'est une question d'infrastructure et
on peut penser que dans un avenir
- un proche on équipera des parkings
publics ou même des parcomètres qui
permettrait à la fois d'assurer le
parking du véhicule également l'argent
des batteries une recharge même
partielle éventuellement entre midi et
deux heures par exemple c'est une
voiture très agréable pour une fin en
particulier puisque l'entretien est très
réduit
la conduite très facile et ce devrait
donc une voiture avec laquelle on
n'aurait pas avoir d'ennuis
[Musique]